Next question.
Hey, David, will Corona virus finally be the
catalyst we need for people to do mass call
outs of work?
Large scale strikes, coordinated mortgage
and rent defaults and all of those other protest
and activism techniques that you've been talking
about?
Beautiful question.
I have talked about those techniques before.
I've said many, many times signing petitions
online.
OK.
Calling your elected officials great.
But that in order to really change the system
from the point of view of an activist, you
may have to be willing to participate in some
other types of protest.
And this includes, as the question asks.
Large scale strikes, mass call outs, strategic
defaults, etc.
The question of whether a corona virus will
cause that to happen really comes down to
one element.
And that's how long does this all last.
And the reason I say that is that for a lot
of people, the twelve hundred dollars stimulus
is not going to be enough.
People on unemployment will be able to sort
of remain afloat treading water.
Assuming that this doesn't last that much
longer than what the models suggest.
And most people.
And this is a feature of the system, not a
bug.
From the purposes of corporate, the corporatocracy,
as soon as things start to open back up, people
are going to have to go back to work.
OK, this is how the system is designed.
So I often say to you, one of the impediments
to mass rallies to change the system is that
the system makes it so that people have to
keep going to work.
People would potentially lose health insurance
if they bail on their job.
The system is insulated from being changed
by how it sort of controls the people that
are working within the system.
So in the same way right now, a lot of people
are staying home and people understand, particularly
on the left, that you've got to stay home
to stop the spread of the virus.
So right now, you're not going to see those
mass rallies because people are doing the
right thing once things start to open up.
The people who have been staying home are
also likely to understand the importance of
getting back to work, to feed their families
and to get caught up with rent or mortgages
or whatever the case may be.
So the system has a way of perpetuating itself
by always making it difficult and inconvenient
and very risky to actually go out and do that
type of protesting.
Now, as far as, you know, formal rent strikes,
for example, a coordinated rent strike would
be large swaths of people say we are not paying
rent on this day or we are not paying our
mortgages on this day, a strategic mortgage
default.
There is no doubt that if it comes down to
you, pay your rent or you buy food or you
buy medication.
I would expect that rent comes after food
and medication.
Of course, every situation is different.
Depends.
What is the medication I get?
But generally speaking, that is probably the
case.
But remember, evictions have been slowed down
or stopped in many areas.
There are places that have done rent and mortgage
deferrals.
Now, importantly, that's not forgiveness.
A lot of people, I hope, are our understanding,
but I fear that some people are not.
When you talk about a rent deferral for three
months, that means you don't pay April 1,
May 1, June 1 rent.
But on July 1, you owe all four months.
Now, maybe it'll be phased.
Then maybe you've got to make up half of each
of the deferred months per month through the
end of the year or something like that.
Still, a lot of it is up in the air, but those
deferrals are only deferrals.
It is not forgiveness.
And that is going to be a problem on the tail
end for a lot of people.
If you needed to defer one months of rent,
are we likely to imagine that you're going
to be able to afford four months of rent on
July 1st?
It doesn't strike me that way.
But again, when it comes to the system, I
don't know that you will see as many rent
and strategic mortgage defaults because evictions
and foreclosures have been slowed down or
stopped in many parts of the country.
And again, it's the system perpetuating itself,
the system protecting itself.
This gets me back to the beginning.
Ultimately, this will depend on how long this
goes.
It's early, but there are starting to be some
improving numbers in many U.S. states and
in many countries around the world.
Social distancing must remain, but it is not
crazy to think that at some point in the not
too distant future, I allow the doctors to
tell us when I'm not even going to speculate.
Some elements of the economy may be ready
to be open back up, including with young workers,
people who test positive for antibodies, meaning
they've already built an immunity to the Corona
virus, et cetera.
And that one factor, how long this goes and
how successfully we stop the spread is going
to be primarily the determining factor as
to how motivated people are to look at large
scale strikes, mass call outs, etc..
My prediction is anybody who can get back
to work whenever it is, mostly people are
going to be glad to do that.
And given the choice between starting to earn
money immediately or going in striking most
people.
I'm not saying this is good or bad, I'm just
saying this is.
Most people are going to choose to get back
to work and to start earning money.
That's my my prediction.
Let me know if you disagree.
Let me know what you think should happen with
regard to mass rallies and call outs.
We've got a fantastic bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join PAC and Duck.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.